bien mes chers collègues nous
poursuivons les travaux de notre mission
d'information sur le développement d'une
filière de bio car de biocarburant
carburant synthétique durable et
hydrogène vert en recevant ce midi 13h30
Madame Agnès panier rue nachier une
hachée ministre de la transition je suis
désolé et de la transition énergétique
je rappelle que cette réunion est captée
et diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat sur lequel elle pourra
ensuite être consultée en vidéo à la
demande
madame la ministre notre mission
d'information comprend des membres issus
des différentes commissions et qui
représentent l'ensemble des groupes
politiques du Sénat le développement des
filières de biocarburant carburant
synthétique durable et hydrogène vert
représente un enjeu important pour
permettre à la France et à l'Union
européenne
d'atteindre l'objectif de neutralité
carbone à l'horizon 2050 mais aussi pour
notre souveraineté et la compétitivité
de notre économie nous avons suivi les
batailles que vous avez menées au niveau
du Conseil de l'Union européenne pour
faire prendre en compte de manière
adaptée la production d'hydrogène ou de
carburant de synthèse produit à partir
d'électricité nucléaire
si l'on veut atteindre les objectifs
ambitieux de le que l'Union et les États
membres se sont fixés au travers de la
loi européenne sur le climat et du
paquet ajustement objectif 55 il nous
semble qu'il faut actionner tous les
leviers d'énergie décarbonée
si nous ne le faisons pas nous nous
trouverons dans une impasse et nous
serons condamnés à des importations
massives d'énergie alors que nous avons
la possibilité de renforcer notre
souveraineté énergétique la capacité à
produire suffisamment d'électricité est
un défi majeur de même nous ne devons
pas être naïf vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires et néanmoins concurrents les
États-Unis la Chine mais également de
nombreux acteurs se mobilisent et
déploient des moyens importants nous ne
pouvons l'ignorer nous souhaitons
évidemment avoir votre perception de ces
différents ajeux et de notre capacité à
développer des filières industrielles
performantes cohérente et économiquement
viable notre rapporteur monsieur Vincent
capo canelas qui est à l'origine de
cette mission vous a adressé un
questionnaire qui peut être qui peut
vous servir de guide mais vous pouvez
mettre introduire comme vous l'entendez
je passerai ensuite la parole à notre
apport puis à l'ensemble de mes
collègues afin qu'ils puissent vous
relancer vous poser un certain nombre de
questions vos services pourront
transmettre ultérieurement des réponses
écrites à la mission madame la ministre
chère Agnès panier rue nachée je vous
cède la parole pour une quinzaine de
minutes mais si vous prenez un peu plus
de temps personne ne vous en voudra
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
merci beaucoup de me donner l'occasion
de découvrir cette salle je ne
connaissais pas encore c'est aussi le
bénéfice des missions d'information et
des missions
d'enquêtes en tant que ministre de la
transition énergétique je porte
l'ambition fixée par le Président de la
République d'atteindre la neutralité
carbone d'ici 2050 ce qui veut dire
qu'il que la France doit être un des
premiers grands pays industriels à
sortir des énergies fossiles cela ne va
pas de soi contrairement aux idées
reçues puisque vous le savez un peu plus
de 60% de notre consommation d'énergie
et d'origine fossile aujourd'hui et
continue d'être importés des quatre
coins du monde avec les conséquences que
nous savons sur notre balance
commerciale sortir des énergies fossiles
du gaz et du Pétrole et donc tout à la
fois un impératif climatique économique
énergétique et géopolitique
afin d'y parvenir la première ministre
chargée de la planification écologique a
présenté le 22 mai dernier la
trajectoire de décarbonation de notre
pays cette trajectoire implique
d'accélérer l'effort des gens engagés
dans tous les secteurs et évidemment
cela concerne au premier chef le secteur
des transports qui représente
aujourd'hui 30% de nos émissions
comme votre mission a dû vous le
démontrer la marche est très haute les
émissions du secteur devront baisser
d'environ 42 millions de tonnes de CO2
pour passer d'un peu près 130 millions
de tonnes aujourd'hui à près de 85-87
millions de tonnes en 2030 ce qui
implique de jouer sur tous les leviers à
notre disposition la sobriété
énergétique en roulant moins en roulant
moins vite
rendant moins souvent le report modal le
covoiturage l'efficacité des véhicules
la décarbonation de l'énergie utilisée
dans ces véhicules le fait de
privilégier des propositions de
transport en commun sur du transport
individuel tout doit être mis en oeuvre
pour décroître une consommation de
carburant qui représente en 2022 42
millions de mètres cubes de diesel et
GNR 13 millions de mètres cubes
d'essence 8 millions de mètres cubes de
kérosène et 2,5 millions de mètres cubes
de car grand maritime pour un total
d'environ 650 dirawattheure c'est énorme
dont la majorité provenant du pétrole
c'est plus que ce que nous produisons
d'électricité pour fixer les idées pour
y parvenir comme je vous le disais nous
devons en priorité réduire la
consommation par la sobriété et
l'efficacité dans un contexte de prix
l'énergie élevé permettent aux ménage de
réduire leur consommation de carburant
c'est très directement réduire leur
facture pour y parvenir l'autre levier
l'utilisation de technologie alternative
aux technologies fossiles et donc les
carburants alternatifs comme les
biocarburants ou les carburants de
synthèse c'est à levier parmi d'autres
de parvenir à cette neutralité carbone
un levier qui ne doit pas être opposé à
la réduction de la consommation de
carburant à la réduction de la taille
des véhicules ou encore à
l'électrification directe dans les
secteurs où cela est possible car il est
au contraire tout à fait complémentaire
et d'ailleurs vous indiquez dans votre
propos liminaire monsieur le Président
que toutes les énergies décarbonées
doivent être utilisées au service de la
neutralité climatique et sur ce point là
nous serons évidemment totalement en
accord
vos auditions vous l'ont montré la
politique française de soutien au
biocarburant n'est pas nouvelle elle
date des années 2000 perçue initialement
et uniquement comme un soutien à la
création de débouchés en aval pour nos
filières agricoles et il est aujourd'hui
un de nos leviers pour l'atteinte de nos
objectifs d'énergie renouvelable un
sujet rapidement émergé c'est celui de
la concurrence des usages avec
l'alimentaire
ce débat me paraît avoir été tranché
autour d'un compromis équilibré le
maintien des niveaux de 2022 plus ou
moins 1% avec un maximum
au maximum un plafond à 7% de l'énergie
fournie au secteur des transports et
l'exclusion de matière critiques du type
huile de palme et ses dérivés et en
France soja
ce plafond il est inscrit dans la loi
européenne il est inscrit dans le code
de l'énergie dans le code des douanes
dans notre stratégie nationale de lutte
contre la déforestation importée et donc
il me semble qu'à ce stade il donne une
bonne visibilité aux acteurs qu'il n'y a
pas de lieu de réouvrir à court terme ni
à la hausse ni à la baisse se plafond la
France vous le savez a été le premier
pays à exclure palmet soja et a été
suivi par ses voisins par ailleurs en
France le dispositif de la tire verte a
fait ses preuves et a notamment permis
en une dizaine d'années la structuration
d'une filière biodésale et bioéthanol
aujourd'hui la tire verte s'élargit
progressivement à l'hydrogène notamment
celui utilisé pour le raffinage des
carburants et au carburants de synthèse
pour contribuer à l'émergence de ces
filières les objectifs vous les
connaissez 9,5% dans les sens 8,6 dans
le diesel 1% dans le co-érosène ils
augmenteront en 2024 9 9 dans les
essences 9% dans le diesel 1,5% dans le
kérosène on a donc une trajectoire qui
est d'ailleurs assez claire
d'incorporation augmentée qui permet
effectivement de baisser nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre un point
d'attention qui va être un point
d'attention qui je dois je pense doit
être un fil conducteur dans nos
politiques de décarbonation c'est la
question du coup et de qui peut le payer
les carburants alternatifs coûtent par
nature plus cher que le pétrole sinon
ils ont évidemment déjà remplacé les
carburants fossiles cela est vrai pour
la première génération et il est encore
plus aujourd'hui pour les biocarburants
avancés qui peuvent coûter entre 3 et 4
fois plus cher que le fossile voir
s'agissant du kérosène de synthèse 6 à 8
fois plus cher donc au fur et à mesure
de l'augmentation des objectifs
d'incorporation le surco pour être de
plus en plus important si dans certains
secteurs il peut être supporté par le
consommateur final il peut cette
ce mouvement peut-être plus difficile un
exemple si le carburant E85 est beaucoup
moins moins cher à la pompe c'est parce
que nous avons et vous avez choisi de le
défiscaliser fortement sinon laisserez
aujourd'hui plus cher que les sens pour
donner un ordre de grandeur l'avantage
fiscal de ticepe octroyé par l'État en
2022 à le 85 par rapport à le 10 y
compris en tenant compte de la
différence de contenu énergétique et
donc d'une surconsommation de 25% en
volume pour le 85 c'est 350 millions
d'euros environ de soutien
budgétaire différenciés avec la
croissance des volumes secoue va
continuer à sa croître c'est un enjeu
clé que nous devons contenir
collectivement garder en tête dans notre
trajectoire et notre politique en
matière de biocarburant
alors où allons-nous nous le savons si
chaque type de transport assez
spécificité ces contraintes
l'électrification directe reste la
solution la plus efficace climatiquement
on imagine bien que s'il faut de
l'électricité par exemple pour produire
certains types de carburant il y a une
perte d'efficacité il vaut mieux
directement utiliser
l'électricité à cet égard le règlement
européen sur les véhicules à fixer un
cap de 2035 pour les véhicules neufs
nous devons tenir ce cap qui est au cœur
de l'atteinte de la neutralité carbone
tant au niveau européen que français
toutefois pour les poids lourds les
choses sont
pas totalement précises encore la
Commission à proposer 90%
d'électrification des véhicules neufs en
2040 et la position française n'est pas
encore arrêtée notamment car les
annonces de constructeur de poids lourds
sur l'électrique ont été plus rapides et
ambitieuses que nous l'avions prévu
initialement lorsque j'étais en charge
de l'Industrie il y a deux ans il
apparaissait que l'électrification
n'était pas une voie Prat pour les poids
lourds aujourd'hui sur la base des
derniers modèles livrés il apparaît que
ce puissent être une technologie
praticable donc vous voyez ça bouge très
vite et effectivement un des grands
enjeux que nous aurions collectivement à
faire c'est d'adapter nos politiques
toujours dans un dans une posture de
neutralité technologique tout en
essayant de donner des signaux moyens
termes au agents économiques qui
investissent et qui eux doivent pouvoir
amortir leur investissement
en tout état de cause nous pourrons nous
pouvons avoir des besoins de
biocarburant pour des secteurs qui
apparaissent plus difficiles à
électrifier je pense par exemple aux
engins agricoles aux engins de BTP ou
encore au train sur les portions
difficilement électrifiables et je crois
savoir que vous avez justement
additionné la SNCF sur le sujet
les biocarburants pourraient être
progressivement orienté vers ces
secteurs mais au-delà deux secteurs vont
bien sûr déterminer la croissance du
marché des carburants alternative dans
les années à venir ce sont l'aérien et
le maritime de secteurs cruciaux dont la
transition énergétique est un véritable
défi de secteurs où nous devons nous
mettre en position de structurer des
filières françaises compétitives
toutefois nous ne pourrons pas affronter
ces défis si nous ne savons pas résoudre
en amont les enjeux de disponibilité en
biomasse et en électricité des carbonées
compétitive et abondante leur
disponibilité déterminera aussi nos
besoins d'importation de renforcement du
rythme de la baisse de consommation
c'est tout le sens de l'action que je
porte en ce moment pour déterminer les
grands axes de notre planification
énergétique en vue de la première loi
sur la planification énergétique que
j'aurai l'honneur de porter au Parlement
à l'automne c'est une réflexion à
laquelle j'ai d'ailleurs proposé
d'associer chacun des groupes politiques
[Musique]
concernant les carburantes synthèse la
clé et la production d'électricité des
carbonées à un coût économiquement
acceptable un accès à des stocks de CO2
biogéniques ou captés directement dans
l'atmosphère et une demande pour
emporter les productions de molécules de
synthèse
concernant cette production
d'électricité des carbonées vous
connaissez mon travail sur ce point avec
la loi d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables et la relance du nucléaire
outre la production toutes les marges
que nous réussirons à dégager par
ailleurs par la sobriété l'efficacité
énergétique seront précieuses pour
parvenir au bouclage global donc pour
résumer sur biocarburant le verrou c'est
de l'accessibilité à la biomasse avec
des usages qui sont prioritaires qui
sont les usages alimentaires et le pic
carbone pour les carburants de synthèse
le verrou c'est la capacité à produire
de l'électricité à un coût compétitif
comparé à d'autres producteurs et en
quantité suffisante par rapport aux
autres usages que nous en aurons
sur notre territoire
vous le savez peut-être les actes
délégués de la directive renouvelables 2
concernant l'additionnalité
l'électricité utilisée le calcul en
analyse encyclotovie de ces carburants
nous donne un avantage compétitif en
reconnaissant le mix des carboné de la
France donc de ce point de vue là nous
avons un accès plus aisé à des solutions
décarbonées en France qui pourront être
valorisés au plan international puisque
nous ne sommes le seul pays avec la
Suède avoir une électricité décarbonée à
plus de 90%. le troisième pays qui
pourra revendiquer cela probablement
avant la fin des années 2030 avant le
début des années pardon avant 2030 c'est
la Finlande
cela va dans le bon sens même si je
continue à me battre au niveau européen
pour la reconnaissance pleine et entière
du nucléaire comme outil de
décarbonation dans tous les textes qui
mentionnent la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
sur les priorités pour les années à
venir tout d'abord je pense à la mise en
place d'une filière maritime dans le
tiroir je compte en effet proposer
d'inscrire en loi de finance un objectif
spécifique pour le maritime à partir de
2025 afin de mettre en oeuvre le
règlement fioulou maritime cela devra
bien sûr se faire en bonne concertation
avec les acteurs du secteur dans le même
temps les autres objectifs devront eux
être augmentés je pense en particulier à
l'aérien afin de coller avec le contenu
du texte review aviation ces objectifs
ont un mérite c'est qu'ils permettent
aussi de donner des signaux à la filière
industrielle puisque elle saura des
bénéficiera de déboucher du fait de ses
obligations d'incorporation
dans nos autres objectifs le
développement d'une filière reposant sur
les cultures intermédiaires pourrait
être intéressant elles sont déjà en
développement pour le biogaz et demain
il pourrait y avoir des cultures
oléagineuses pour la production de
bio-carburant utilisable pour aller
l'aérien par exemple
j'apporte toutefois un mais à cette
perspective sur les cultures
intermédiaires il faut s'assurer de leur
qualité agronomique et que cela
n'appauvrisse pas les sols cela est bien
prévu dans la définition européenne il
nous y serons attentifs car bien exécuté
ces cultures intermédiaires apportent
effectivement une capacité de production
énergétique complémentaire et peuvent
avoir un impact positif sur la réduction
du besoin en anglais et le stockage de
carbone des terres sur lesquelles elles
sont mises en œuvre
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
voilà ce que je tenais à vous dire
aujourd'hui pour nourrir votre travail
dans cette mission d'information je me
tiens maintenant votre disposition afin
de répondre à vos questions
merci beaucoup madame mamie
monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la ministre de votre présence c'est pour
nous importante de pouvoir échanger à ce
stade de nos travaux et je pense que les
collègues auront un certain de questions
j'ai peut-être me limiter à me poser
deux ou trois au début premier point
vous l'avez abordé il y a encore un
débat européen
sur notamment red 3 ou est-ce que vous
en êtes il y a la question nucléaire qui
reste encore à finir de négocier si je
puis dire il y a eu des pas mais quel
est l'état des lieux
deuxièmement vous avez dit des choses
sur la première génération de
biocarburant avec le plafond à 7% si
bien compris on ne change pas ni à la
hausse ni à la baisse
bon ce qui veut dire quand même à terme
une baisse bon en pratique en fait il y
aura moins de volume
sur la deuxième génération j'ai compris
que on pouvait jouer peut-être sur la
sur les objectifs d'incorporation sur
sur la tire verte mais est-ce qu'il
n'est pas nécessaire d'avoir d'autres
éléments plus incitatifs
pour faire décoller cette deuxième
génération et puis les raffineurs on a
pu voir tout ce qui travaille sur ces
questions là les distributeurs nous
disent qu'il y a quand même un sujet
d'investissement
quelle est la démarche qu'on peut
conduire pour que réellement cette
deuxième génération sorte enfin comme on
est au quelques jours du Salon du
Bourget le monde aérien un peu
rendez-vous avec cette exigence de
décarbonation
des auditions que nous avons entendu
elle est partagée et le monde aérien
s'est mis en situation mais grosso modo
les transporteurs et les industriels
nous disent quand même bien souvent on a
deux problèmes la disponibilité des
biocarburants et des carburants
synthétiques demain et le prix du coup
est-ce qu'on est rentré dans une logique
où il va falloir se fournir à l'étranger
aux États-Unis ou en tout cas hors Union
Européenne pour pour cette filière là
merci monsieur le rapporteur
alors sur la question de Red 3 le débat
qui se construit aujourd'hui serait
trois n'est pas sur le nucléaire il est
sur la décarbonation profonde de
certains sites industriels dont lequel
calendrier de décarbonation profonde ne
serait pas aux risquerait de tamponner
le calendrier qui est précisé dans la
directive red 3 d'atteinte d'objectifs
d'électricité renouvelable et non
fossiles je le précise parce qu'il y a
eu
un petit peu de de comment dire
de discussions qui qui ont pu être
relayées par des médias mais qui ne
correspondent pas à la réalité des
discussions puisque s'agissant du
nucléaire l'équilibre auquel nous sommes
parvenus c'est-à-dire une reconnaissance
de l'hydrogène bas carbone dans la
directive red 3 conjuguée au fait que la
France bénéficie au titre de son mix
électrique décarbonée à 90% d'une
d'un avantage compétitif lié au
nucléaire
correspondait aux objectifs que nous
nous étions donnés donc précision
utile
sur le carburant de deuxième génération
donc sur la première génération on est
sur un équilibre de 7% qui a priori
n'est pas une incitation à la diminution
mais qui sauf à diminué effectivement
dans drastiquement nos consommations de
carburant aujourd'hui on est plutôt dans
une stabilité ou une légère progression
notre objectif était effectivement de
réduire ses consommations et vous avez
constaté que j'ai dit à ce stade
considérant que dans la dynamique des
trois quatre cinq années dans lequel
nous étions le plafond de 7% nous
paraissait avec une petite capacité de
variation correspondre à une situation
de marché équilibré sur la deuxième
génération qui est un peu une enveloppe
pour tout de différentes technologies
le gouvernement a mis en oeuvre sous
l'égide du président de la République au
travers de France 2030 un certain nombre
d'appels à projets qui permettent de
soutenir des nouvelles technologies que
ce soit d'ailleurs
dans les safs donc carburant pour
aviation ou sur du maritime
et nous allons
comment dire accompagner les industriels
qui seraient en capacité de proposer non
seulement
des des avancées technologiques ou des
productions de nouvelles générations
mais des lignes industrielles pas
seulement la R&D qui est soutenue mais
également l'industrialisation
de ces productions et vous savez
d'ailleurs que il y a des projets de
transformation de raffinerie qui sont
aujourd'hui à l'oeuvre sur sur notre
territoire je sais que le Président de
la République prendra la parole vendredi
sur la question de la décarbonation de
de l'aviation donc je le laisserai
donner sa vision notamment de l'avenir
et des soutiens que nous apporterons à
l'aéronautique et dans une optique de
décarbonation
de manière plus générale notre
dispositif d'accompagnement il repose
sur trois piliers en premier pilier qui
est l'accompagnement recherche
développement préindustrialisation
industrialisation ça c'est France 2030
le deuxième pilier ce sont les outils de
type tirer ou on va dire normatif qui
soit au niveau européen tout
d'incorporation au niveau français qui
vont donner une incitation à la
production de ces carburants de deuxième
génération
et puis le le troisième le troisième
outil c'est l'accompagnement au travers
de projets de type industrie verte pour
faciliter l'installation de nouveaux
sites industriels et leur garantir un
niveau de compétitivité suffisante pour
pouvoir produire
de manière crédible sur sur le
territoire français bien entendu le un
des points clés c'est le coût de sortie
de production de ces carburants de
deuxième génération avec à la fois
les avancées technologiques que nous
serons soutenir et qui permettront de
créer un avantage compétitif et de
l'autre côté la réalité des coûts des
entrants et notamment la
compétitivité de la plaque France de
manière générique qui est un point
d'attention comme vous le savez depuis
six ans que le Président de la
République a engagé une politique de
réindustrialisation visant notamment à
chaque fois aller chercher
des écarts de compétitivité qui
pouvaient être
mis en avant par les investisseurs
étrangers en comparaison de nos de nos
concurrents voilà le je dirais à grandes
trail la manière dont nous nous
concevons les soutiens à apporter enfin
dernier point dans le cadre de la loi de
programmation énergique climat
la question alors je l'ai dit des
[Musique]
usages de la biomasse et grosso modo des
grands enjeux autour des biocarburants
seront appelés à être traités avec une
volonté de donner la visibilité aux
acteurs c'est une loi de programmation
mais ça reste une façon de donner de la
stabilité aux investisseurs qui se
positionneront sur ce marché ce sera
aussi l'occasion s'agissant de rifiot
l'aviation et de la partie aussi
maritime de transposer
les textes européens pour là aussi
donner cette visibilité et cette
sécurité aux investisseurs dans ces
secteurs
bien merci la valise de façon à
respecter nos horaires respectives les
vôtres et les nôtres je vais demander à
trois collègues de poser leurs questions
et puis je vous redonnerai la parole
pierre kuiperce et merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre j'aurais
aimé avoir plus de détails sur le fait
que vous restiez bleu bloqué à 7 %
d'incorporation sachant que l'ensemble
des outils industriels de transformation
des stérifications ou autre aujourd'hui
sont surdimensionnés pour être pour
atteindre à peu près 9% voire 9 et demi
pour cent sachant que vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure qu'il fallait prioriser
la biomasse
pour l'alimentation humaine et pour
l'alimentation animale j'ose vous
rappeler ici que l'alimentation animale
plus vous produirez de biocarburant plus
vous produirez de protéines nécessaires
à l'alimentation animale c'est tout à
fait l'inverse je crois que essayer de
me démontrer le contraire si vous voulez
mais je crois que ce n'est pas le bon
raisonnement
plus vous produirez de bio carburant
puis vos produirez de biomasse et de
matières premières alimentaires et des
protéines pour l'alimentation animale
Vincent
Ségouin merci
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
le Ministre j'ai entendu vos propos sur
réduire la consommation
alors d'un côté on a une population qui
augmente et il faut réduire la
consommation réduire on constate aussi
et quand on a auditionné le le président
de DP il nous a bien expliqué que quand
on fait une projection sur sur le
transport aérien ce sera ce sera
exponentiel ça va ça va augmenter donc
je suis très inquiet par vos propos dans
le sens où je me dis est-ce qu'on va pas
passer à côté de l'économie de demain
est-ce que on va continuer à aller dans
cette déficit de la balance que
commerciale que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
est-ce que ma question c'est simple
c'est vos orientations sont-elles bonnes
je m'inquiète parce que le nucléaire
vous nous dites aujourd'hui je crois
dans le nucléaire mais il y a pas encore
très longtemps vous étiez anti-nucléaire
vous vous nous dites tout électrique
vous ne dites les poids lourds les cars
etc tout le monde va passer au tout
électrique et la technologie avance très
vite pourtant quand on interroge des
acteurs ils nous disent mais attendez
des batteries prennent l'ensemble la
place l'espace de l'ensemble des valises
donc comment on peut transporter du
monde demain donc voilà je suis vraiment
très inquiet j'ai l'impression que il y
a que le calendrier qui compte
et que on va encore faire les frais et
on va avoir une industrie en face qui va
pas être en mesure de pouvoir répondre à
ce calendrier qui est assez simple dans
les dans les textes et qu'on va
continuer de voir ce que l'on vous vit
aujourd'hui déjà quand vous voyez le
nombre de l'effondrement de la de la
vente automobile c'est un vrai
fondrement de 2 millions de véhicules
vendus en 2019 on est passé à un million
529 000 c'est on vit un effondrement on
vit des les Français ne savent plus du
tout où on veut aller comment on va
aller et voilà je ma question c'est
est-ce que vous êtes sûr de votre
politique et est-ce qu'elle est
réellement mature dans les faits merci
Béatrice Gosselin et puis après je
reviendrai
bonjour Madame le Ministre moi ça
reprend une question que Vincent a déjà
évoqué ce concernant les poids lourds
puisque vous avez parlé de
essentiellement une technique concernant
les batteries on a pu voir dans
différentes
cours de différentes auditions et même à
Lyon que s'assemblait compliqué d'avoir
des batteries qui coupaient très lourdes
dans un véhicule ça n'est plus du tout
performant alors peut-être qu'il y a une
évolution mais on a l'impression qu'on
part plutôt sur batterie et hydrogène et
non pas et non pas vraiment batterie
toute seule donc moi c'était vraiment
une question là-dessus est-ce que
réellement l'évolution est telle que on
pourra se limiter à des véhicules lourds
tels que des poids lourds avec
uniquement des batteries
le fait que j'ouvre des perspectives sur
une réalité technologique qui est
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons des solutions
en matière de poids lourds électrifiés
qui sont d'ailleurs produits en France
s'agissant des plus de 5 tonnes ne dit
pas qu'on va arrêter tout le reste et
d'ailleurs je suis un petit peu étonné
de la manière dont vous formuler des
objectifs alors que pour le coup à aucun
moment je n'ai indiqué que nous étions
nous faisions des allers-retours nous
avons des une politique qui est
parfaitement claire en matière
énergétique qui est d'ailleurs
directement
la translation des recommandations des
experts en matière internationale à la
fois sur le climat mais aussi sur
l'énergie et sur les questions de
compétitivité sobriété énergétique
efficacité énergétique production
d'énergie renouvelable production de
nucléaire j'ai rien inventé par contre
je le mets en oeuvre et avec une
traçabilité très claire puisque vous
avez une loi d'accélération sur les
énergies renouvelables et 30 textes qui
ont été mis en œuvre vous avez une
augmentation des budgets sur la
rénovation thermique et des incitations
très claires mais pas seulement sur
l'électrique et un respect strict d'un
principe qui est la neutralité
technologique la neutralité
technologique elle nous invite à
constamment vérifier quelles sont les
solutions qui sont les plus capacitaires
les moins coûteuses pour les Français et
les plus accessibles pour nos
entreprises c'est ce que nous faisons
très simplement sans condamner aucun
aucune piste et je l'ai dit en
introduction c'est à dire que en toute
évidence nous nous respectons la
neutralité technologique et nous avons
également le souhait d'adapter nos
politiques à chaque fois qu'il y a une
innovation technologique si c'est une
très bonne nouvelle et je pense qu'il
faut l'accueillir positivement
collectivement notre filière
industrielle est capable de produire des
véhicules lourds qui fonctionnent à
l'électricité c'est pas moi qui vais
leur dire que ça fonctionne pas ceux qui
le mettent au point et qu'il est mettent
à disposition aujourd'hui à un coût
élevé le sujet c'est à la comment dire
la convergence de coûts vers des niveaux
de qui soit plus accessible et c'est
notre responsabilité politique
effectivement de faire émerger ses
filières industrielles comme nous
l'avons fait sur d'autres secteurs je
rappelle que sur les batteries
électriques il y a 6 ans lorsque nous
lançons le projet de pierre avec lorsque
nous défendions au niveau européen le
projet de soutien à la filière batterie
électrique tout le monde nous rit au nez
et bien moi j'ai eu le plaisir à la fin
du mois de mai d'inauguré la première
ligne de batterie électrique en France
qui aujourd'hui produit et ça fonctionne
et c'est dans les hautes France et c'est
plusieurs milliers d'emplois à la clé et
au total il y aura quatre usines dans
les hauts de France ça c'est une réalité
industrielle que nous mettons en place
et on fait pareil sur tous les autres
sujets l'hydrogène ne condamne pas
l'électricité l'électricité donc on n'a
pas le biocarburant et ce qu'on sait de
manière un peu près certaine c'est que
en fait vous avez des solutions qui sont
multi factorielles il y aura un peu de
tout
et au fil de de technologie et des
innovations le marché s'ajustera de
façon à privilégier les
les filières les plus compétitives et
notre objectif c'est de faire en sorte
que la France soit capable de sortir des
filières compétitives
sur la question de la réduction de
consommation là encore je veux rappeler
ici que cette politique de sobriété que
nous avons menée l'hiver dernier a
permis de réduire de 12% notre
consommation gaz et électricité combiné
au cours de l'hiver 12% que cela a
permis de baisser nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre au total de l'année de
2,5%. et sur la seule filière sur le
seul secteur des bâtiments de
15%. est-ce que ça a coûté des points de
croissance non
à quel moment vous avez vu que la
croissance a fait moins 12%. non ça
effectivement permis aux Français de
payer moins cher leur facture qui était
déjà assez cher parce que c'était il y
avait un intérêt à agir aux entreprises
de payer moins cher et aujourd'hui ces
habitudes de pilotage notamment de la
gestion technique des bâtiments et bien
elles sont considérées comme
bonne et à perpétuer et c'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est l'enquête menée par la
MF auprès de l'ensemble des maires de
France sur la question du colza enfin je
pense que vous faites référence au
groupe appris alors il se trouve que
c'est un petit peu c'est un groupe que
je connais bien j'en ai fait l'ouverture
de capital il y a 15 ans lorsque j'étais
à la Caisse des dépôts à l'époque ça
s'appelait encore soprol sous les idées
du récemment disparu Philippe
tilouzborde vous avez raison de dire
qu'il y a une concurrence entre
coproduit et
production de colzaïque le coproduit qui
sont les tourteaux de colza sont un des
leviers de
diminution des importations de tourteau
de soja notamment venus d'Amérique
latine
et que il y a un effet mais l'huile de
colza elle peut être aussi utilisée à
d'autres fins notamment alimentaires ce
que je veux préciser c'est que
précisément en excluant le soja et le
palme vous donnez plus d'espace
à la partie biocarburant sur base colza
donc il y a des perspectives de
croissance au sein de cette enveloppe de
7% qui a encore une fois à date non
représente nous semble être un bon un
bon équilibre en matière de
[Musique]
pardon un bon équilibre en matière de de
plafond mais dont je dis pas qu'il faut
pas revenir dessus de tout éternité
voilà on a réussi à stabiliser quelque
chose ça donne une vision aux acteurs on
sort l'huile de palme et on sort le soja
ça donne plus d'espace au colza c'est
une entreprise française qui a des sites
industriels tout à fait méritants et
effectivement
soyons fiers de cette industrie c'est
pas moi qui qui dirais le contraire et
peut-être je reviens juste un instant
sur les
il peut avoir sur la partie huile de
colza mais par ailleurs vous faites du
coproduit qui est du tourteau de colza
et vous avez raison à ce titre là je
reviens juste un instant sur les poids
lourds oui c'est intéressant de faire de
l'hydrogène et oui c'est intéressant
d'avoir un une combinatoire hydrogène
électrique en fait encore une fois
autorisons-nous à être ouvert aux
différentes technologies avec des
avancées qui sont parfois plus rapides
que ce que nous imaginions et nous
avions imaginé historiquement des
exclusions qui finalement s'avère
infondé parce que
les constructeurs sont allés plus vite
que nous et c'est très bien je pense que
c'est je regardais les parts de marché
de ce que nous vendions alors c'est en
des unités donc c'est pas le même nombre
que de voitures que vous mentionnez
mais quand on me dit il y a 80% des
poids lourds sur basilic qui sont
fabriqués en France même si c'est pas
beaucoup de poids lourds je trouve que
c'est une bonne chose depuis le plus de
5 on a un peu moins de part de marché
sur les moins de 5 tonnes donc il faut
vraiment regarder aussi dans nos
politiques comment elles ont des enfin
quelles sont leurs retombées en termes
d'empreintes industrielles et comment ça
peut aider effectivement à structurer
des filières particulières c'est ce que
j'appelle ne pas être naïf je crois que
c'est ça aussi que vous faisiez
référence monsieur le Président c'est de
mettre quelques barrières à l'entrée
lorsque il y a une remise en question de
la concurrence loyale que d'autres
entreprises sont lourdement
subventionnées sur leur territoire et
importe ensuite un coût ultra compétitif
sur notre territoire et c'est aussi
apprendre à structurer des filières en
donnant de la visibilité aux industriels
en permettant d'avoir accès
respectant les règles du jeu de la
concurrence mais à des marchés publics
dès lors qu'elle remplisse des cahiers
des charges d'empreintes
environnementales ou de close sociale
avant de retourner dans mes collègues
sur le rapporteur
l'inquiétude qui était dans la question
de Béatrice Gosselin on a entendu un
certain d'entreprise du secteur des
travaux publics d'ailleurs pour le GNR
et puis du secteur routier notamment
routier longue distance avec une
véritable inquiétude pour des PME
familiales parfois à qui on annonce des
prix lorsqu'on parle de camions
électriques ou à pile à combustible qui
sont hors de hors d'atteinte donc un
vrai souci d'accompagnement de ces
filières là et elles viennent vers nous
en nous disant finalement les
biocarburants prennent aussi ce serait
quand même pas si mal c'est pas une
rupture technologique il saurait faire
donc il y a un conflit vous l'avez
abordé vous-même on voit bien enfin il y
a une attente y compris du ferroviaire
pour la partie qui ne peut pas être
électrifiée on va faire des choix là
dedans mais en tout cas on a senti que
ces deux filières là FNTR pour dire les
choses clairement fnpp l'ont relayé il y
a un vrai besoin de les aider parce que
si on les laisse avec un carburant qui
augmente et finalement pas de
possibilité de renouveler leur flotte il
va y avoir un problème
alors sur ça je vous réponds tout de
suite sur la FNTP pour le moment on n'a
pas d'alternative orbio-carburant ça je
vous rejoins complètement tout ce qui
est engin lourd d'intervention de
travaux publics sur le routier on
commence à avoir une solution
alternative électrique mais qui est
effectivement très coûteuse et qui doit
faire l'objet d'accompagnement à deux
niveaux l'accompagnement sur et vous
savez qu'il y a un appel à projet qui a
été souscrit lancé l'année dernière de
60 millions d'euros qui a permis de
financer quelques camions je encore une
fois je
c'est pas un million de camions c'est
quelques centaines et que je proposerai
dans la discussion budgétaire que nous
aurons de le continuer parce que c'est
comme ça qu'on permet de structurer un
marché et deuxièmement il y a toute la
question des bornes de recharge pour ces
engins particuliers qu'il a aussi
supposent un accompagnement parce que
aujourd'hui elles vont pas émerger sur
le territoire
sans avoir de soutien public donc tout
ça appelle des politiques où
effectivement il faut être cohérent dans
la manière dont on les structures après
je pense que ça serait une faute dès
lors qu'on a des solutions industrielles
françaises de ne pas regarder comment
les structurer et encore une fois ça
n'épuise pas le sujet avec en plus deux
temporalités il y a la temporalité de la
transition c'est à dire des solutions
que l'on peut utiliser aujourd'hui et
qui peut être en 2050 on existeront plus
parce qu'il y aura des alternatives mais
qui dans les 10 ans qui viennent sont
probablement bien positionnés avec des
acteurs industriels et avec des coûts
accessibles pour le consommateur final
et des solutions qu'il faut commencer à
travailler et à produire dans l'optique
qu'elle soit les solutions du futur
rappelez-vous il y a 20 ans le coup des
éoliennes marines ou il y a 10 ans le
coup des premiers panneaux
photovoltaïques c'était pas formidable
et tout le monde s'inquiétait d'être de
subventionnés un secteur qui n'était pas
rentable
finalement aujourd'hui on constate que
ces productions sont rentables parce que
on a accompagné ces filières et qu'il
faut effectivement avoir cette vision
dans le temps qui permet de structurer
cet accompagnement et de faire converger
industriellement vers des prix plus
compétitifs et soutenables merci Martine
oui merci président madame la ministre
merci pour tous les éléments que vous
avez déjà apporté notre mission
d'information porte également sur
l'hydrogène or vous n'en avez pas ou
très peu parlé est-ce à dire que tout a
déjà été fait ou est-ce que le
gouvernement a des projets pour
intensifier sa production sont
transports son utilisation
Daniel salmon
merci
journal la ministre je aimerais avoir
votre éclairage sur la quantification
des gisements de biomasse au fur et à
mesure que nous déroulons sur ces
auditions sur les biocarburants on
s'aperçoit que il y a des vues sur de
nombreux gisements mais qui sont pas
illimités je parlerai tout simplement
des coproduits issus de la filière bois
on sait que la pyrogazéification s'y
intéresse pour faire du méthane on en
fait des pellets on en fait également
des des biocarburants de seconde
génération mais logisement n'est pas
n'est pas infini donc j'aimerais savoir
à peu près comment c'est quantifié
quelle part vous pensez que la biomasse
peut prendre sur les 650 térawatt-heure
que vous nous avez donné comme chiffre
tout à l'heure qu'elle est aussi la part
de la sobriété dans ces 50
terawatt-heure quels sont les objectifs
pour la mobilité 2030 2040 en terme de
de térawat et puis simplement pour une
dernière question concernant le coût que
vous avez annoncé très élevé des
biocarburants de seconde génération
est-ce que pour vous c'est un un coup
qui est transitoire qui est dû à une
face encore de recherche et est-ce que
on peut espérer comme dans d'autres
nombreuses technologies avoir
demain une baisse même si on sait que là
ce n'est pas simplement une question
technologique c'est une question aussi
de gisement c'est pour ça que je reviens
sur cette question du gisement merci
et puis je redonne la parole à même la
ministre et je reviendrai vers vous
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre de deux questions rapides une
générale
où effectivement vous avez fait un peu
le
décompte de ce qui peut se faire alors
en véhicule léger l'électricité
en poids lourds électricité alors qu'on
parle plutôt de pile à combustible
hydrogène voilà après il y a des zones
d'ombres qu'on ne connaît pas alors vous
direz vous vous avez il y aura de tout
alors non auditionne depuis un bon bout
de temps les opérateurs
et je trouve que c'est peut-être ça qui
fait le malaise dans cette affaire là
c'est que
est-ce qu'à un moment donné il y aura
des orientations claires en direction
des industriels parce que il se pose
tous la question alors moi je suis bon
dans tel domaine mais en fait on sait
pas si on va y aller ou si on va pas
donc il y a cette question là que la
deuxième est plus plus ciblée concernant
la question de l'aérien on a reçu des
opérateurs dans l'aérien il se trouve
que on peut utiliser du biocarburant
jusqu'à hauteur de 50 %
les moteurs sont aptes à ça et par
ailleurs on a des coûts de de carburant
qui qui sont excessifs en tout cas en
France puisqu'on parle de
4000 à 5000 euros la tonne alors qu'aux
États-Unis on trouve à 2000 euros quoi
donc votre positionnement c'est quoi par
rapport à ces deux questions s'il vous
plaît
merci
alors sur la question de l'hydrogène oui
on a une on a une stratégie alors je le
dis pour les autres c'est à dire que il
y a des stratégies qui ont d'ores et
déjà été établies ça s'appelle la
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
et elle est en cours de révision et
cette stratégie relativement précise il
y a les travailler en concertation avec
les industriels elle a été travaillée
pour sa version qui a été publiée en
2018 elle est en 2019 d'ailleurs dans le
détail elle est à nouveau travaillée
aujourd'hui dans des groupes de travail
qui associent des sénateurs de chacun de
vos groupes donc ça donc je vais pas
vous donner le résultat de cette
concertation et de ce travail puisque
j'aurai une double réponse sur ça c'est
en cours et en plus il y a un objet qui
s'appelle loi de programmation énergique
climat
votre planification énergétique si on
lui donne un nom peut-être plus simple
qui a vocation à vous être présenté à
l'automne néanmoins les grands axes de
la stratégie a été ont déjà été évoquée
par le Président de la République
c'est-à-dire un objectif à minima de 6,5
gigawatts de production d'hydrogène
bas carbone à horizon 2030 une filière
qui se structure autour des
électrolyseurs des piles à combustibles
et des technologies de stockage à haute
densité avec des projets qui sont
accompagnés à la fois par des appels à
projets de France 2030 mais également
par un projet européen projet
d'importance
d'intérêt commun européen
ipcu qui a permis de soutenir
l'industrialisation d'une dizaine de
solutions alors Faurecia Plastic Omnium
enfin vous connaissez tout cela
une
une réflexion sur l'utilisation et là
aussi une notion de
ordre de mérite pour l'utilisation de
l'hydrogène avec toujours la même
logique qu'est-ce qui aujourd'hui n'a
pas d'alternative et sur lequel on sera
obligé d'utiliser prioritairement de
alternatives de l'hydrogène bas carbone
et qu'est-ce qui est aujourd'hui a
potentiellement des alternatives et où
il faudra privilégier plutôt la solution
la plus facile à déployer et la moins
coûteuse du point de vue du consommateur
donc sur l'hydrogène bas carbone c'est
notamment une solution absolument
essentielle pour la décarbonation de
l'industrie lourde vous connaissez les
projets de ciment vert d'acier vert
de décarbonation des trois filières qui
aujourd'hui sont représentent 75% des
émissions de CO2 industriel en France et
vous savez que mon collègue Roland
Lescure est un terrain de travailler sur
une contractualisation site par site des
56 les plus émetteurs de carbone ou
malgré tout la solution hydrogène bac
carbone et une des solutions les plus
employées alors vous avez éventuellement
du biogaz vous pouvez aussi avoir des
mais vous avez ça tourne autour de ces
gros objets là si on veut vraiment aller
au bout de cette décarbonation sur le
transport c'est un c'est un sujet sur
lequel
on est peut-être un stade un peu moins
avancé on a d'abord au niveau européen
au travers du paquet gaz une législation
qui est en train d'être mise en place
pour être commune sur l'hydrogène donc
on passe du gaz fossile à du gaz bas
carbone et l'hydrogène et classer dans
ces dans ces dans cette catégorie avec
une un questionnement sur les
infrastructures de transport qu'il
faudra mettre en place
de même qu'il faudra peut-être penser à
déterminer
hydrogène
progressivement et au fur et à mesure de
la montée de nos besoins la France fait
aujourd'hui
l'analyse suivante nous devons d'abord
structurer notre filière industrielle
nous sommes plutôt un peu plus en retard
ou en tout cas un peu moins avancé que
d'autres pays européens je pense
notamment à l'Allemagne qui a des bouts
de des briques technologiques plus
avancés mais nous avons avec le travail
qui a été fait ces trois quatre
dernières années des projets des
entreprises bien déterminées des
technologies qui correspondent donc on
couvre désormais
la les différentes briques
technologiques dont nous avons besoin
deuxième temps nous devons produire de
l'hydrogène bas carbone à proximité des
sites qui seront les plus consommateurs
vous allez assez vite sur les grandes
plateformes émettives vous allez trouver
Dunkerque vous allez trouver le a vous
allez trouver Saint-Nazaire Fos-sur-Mer
potentiellement chalandais et Roussillon
qui sont les cinq plateformes
d'industrie lourdes ou associés à
l'industrie lourde très fortement et
maîtrise de carbone et ensuite
effectivement il y a d'autres usages qui
pourront se nécessiter du transport et
là on a des un travail qui est fait
notamment avec
à la fois l'Europe et les régions je
pense au projet Barma qui avait qui a
été annoncé
lors du sommet avec le Portugal et
l'Espagne qui a vocation à relier
Barcelone à Marseille
peut-être en passant par Port la
Nouvelle
de façon à mettre en place la première
structuration d'un
réseau hydrogène là on est sur des
projets qui
ont vocation à aboutir fin des années
2020 début des années 2030 et avec une
nécessité de dessiner un réseau qui soit
à peu près cohérent et qui avance au
rythme des besoins et de nos capacités
de production ou d'importation
d'hydrogène ensuite est-ce qu'on importe
est-ce que on produit en tout état de
cause il faut produire je pense que
c'est quelque chose qu'on a appris de la
la crise covid de la désorganisation des
chaînes logistiques et des différents
difficultés que nous avons eu à
traverser de difficultés
d'approvisionnement mais ça veut pas
dire que ça épuise le sujet donc il faut
maîtriser les technologies premiers pas
avoir une avance technologique c'est un
des éléments de notre compétitivité
s'assurer qu'on a une production
d'électricité bas carbone compétitive
deuxième aspect très important pour être
compétitif dans la durée et troisième
aspect être capable aussi
de regarder comment évolue le marché
mondial et d'être capable de mettre en
place des sourcings qui soient pas
nécessairement un seul pays ou un seul
site mais diversifier pour
pouvoir avoir accès à ces
à cette hydrogène avec une notion de
fournir les sites qui ont lorsqu'ils en
auront besoin c'est à dire que il faudra
faire très attention à ce que cet
hydrogène soit effectivement livré dans
la quantité et les prix qui permettent à
nos industriels de rester en France
quand vous regardez des trajectoires de
sites comme ArcelorMittal ou comme Vicat
les dates sont assez précises de
changement d'équipement et les coûts ou
la l'impact de ces coups sur le coup de
production finale dans des marchés qui
sont très concurrentiels sont
effectivement assez importants d'où
aussi notre grande vigilance par rapport
à des dossiers des démarches comme Lynch
fashion réduction actes et d'où l'enjeu
aussi de la mise en place d'une taxe
carbone aux frontières qui permet de
remettre de la concurrence loyale entre
entre les différents acteurs voilà ce
que je peux vous dire sur sur ce sujet
là sur la quantification des gisements
de biomasse ça a été un très gros
travail qu'on a fait monsieur le
sénateur depuis 9 mois 20 ans pour
essayer de d'avoir une vision qui soit
réaliste
aujourd'hui nous sommes sur un scénario
qui tourne autour de 330 térawatt-heure
de biomasse
dont un peu moins de 40% vient de la
biomasse forestière et autour de 60%,
vient de la biomasse agricole les 4% qui
font la différence étant d'origine des
déchets derrière cela c'est un travail
quand même très important
de production de biomasse sur les
cultures intermédiaires à vocation
énergétique sur la remise en place de et
sur tout le territoire français
je crois que je peux pas dire de bêtises
mais de mémoire le scénario c'est 1,5
millions de kilomètres de haies implanté
d'ici
2050 donc c'est énorme
et c'est effectivement un certain nombre
de leviers dans la gestion par exemple
d'amélioration de la gestion de nos
forêts pour faire en sorte qu'elle soit
opéré de manière durable en intégrant le
changement climatique et en continuant à
produire
suffisamment de biomasse pour pouvoir
être utilisé derrière mais de manière
mais tout en
préservant le bicarbonate donc c'est un
exercice qui n'est pas simple pour dire
le mois et c'est tout l'enjeu que nous
allons avoir
dans les semaines qui viennent lorsqu'on
pose la question à nos groupes de
travail de quels sont les arbitrages à
prendre c'est comment on monte les
curseurs pour produire plus de biomasse
parce que c'est notre intérêt collectif
mais ça veut dire quand même un
changement de nos pratiques agricoles et
c'est pas quelque chose qui se décrète
ou un changement de nos pratiques
forestière mais c'est pas quelque chose
qui se décrète je dirais encore moins
puisque là c'est une propriété foncière
très éclatée parfois
issu enfin je dirais des histoires
familiales donc bon ça fait pas de vous
un grand forestier le fait d'avoir
hérité d'un bout de forêt et puis voilà
il y a c'est une vraie maîtrise
technique de savoir j'aurais
gérer durablement une forêt donc il y a
ce travail là à faire sur lesquels on
bute quand même depuis un certain nombre
d'années et de l'autre côté les usages
de la biomasse c'est-à-dire plus on
mettra d'ambition sur la vocation usée
de la biomasse plus on mettra de la
pression sur notre capacité ou sur
l'enjeu de production de biomasse alors
bien sûr on peut importer de la biomasse
d'ailleurs on le fait déjà
mais il y a des limites
et dans les premiers exercices de
stratégie nationale bas carbone les
premières simulations on avait
effectivement
eu des simulations on avait grosso modo
une biomasse qui représentait la moitié
des usages donc on vendait deux fois
donc là on est arrivé à quelque chose
qui est un peu plus praticable mais avec
un gros niveau d'exigence sur la partie
production de biomasse et une
un questionnement sur la partie
utilisation de la biomasse c'est-à-dire
est-ce que effectivement ces crédible
est-ce que on n'a pas poussé les
curseurs un peu trop loin ça sera parmi
les questions qu'on vous qui sont posées
aujourd'hui dans les groupes de travail
pour avoir le sentiment collectif et
surtout mettre en place les politiques
publiques sous-jacentes qui permettent
d'aller plus loin
alors la question de l'aérien que vous
avez posée donc on peut aller on a déjà
des tests pour aller jusqu'à 100%
d'incorporation
la question de la visibilité donnée aux
filières sur les cas particuliers de la
rien comme je voulais indiquer en amont
du Bourget je crois que le Président de
la République souhaitera faire un point
sur toutes les feuilles de route que
nous avons travaillé avec les filières
et justement tracer ces éléments de
visibilité après il y aura de toute
façon des travaux législatifs et
réglementaires qui qui suivront et de
manière générale l'exercice de
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
qui est fait tous les 5 ans et cet
exercice qui a vocation à donner la
visibilité sur trois séquences
successives de programmation plus réelle
ou vous êtes censé tracer 2024
2024-2028 2029 2033 et pour certaines
questions encore au-delà et moi j'ai une
demande des parlementaires lorsque j'ai
mis en place les groupes de travail de
dire mais d'ailleurs jusqu'en 2050
est-ce que sans être d'une précision
absolue on peut pas déjà commencé à
remplir le cadre pour justement qu'on
ait se consensus ce consensus minimal ou
ce commun minimal sur ces quoi la
politique énergétique dans notre pays
notre sentiment global c'est qu'on a
besoin d'avoir même si on peut être plus
ou moins pro nucléaire plus ou moins pro
efficacité énergétique ou rénovation
thermique mais qu'on est un minimum de
communs et de diagnostic partagé parce
que c'est ça qui fera la solidité
intertemporelle de notre politique et
cette politique elle devra être de toute
façon transpartisane je ne vois pas
d'autres manières de garantir de la
durée dans cette politique
merci
René Paul Savary oui merci justement
suite aux propos de madame la ministre
il faut leur donner confiance au
territoire c'est ça qui est important
hors dans nos territoires ruraux où je
suis du Grand Est ce qu'on voit des
éoliennes c'est des investissements qui
sont pas français c'est des
investissements étrangers les voitures
ont dit tout électrique ces
investissements chinois et on soutient
l'investissement Chinois et les
investissements qui sont faits par les
acteurs du territoire c'est quoi c'est
sur le biogaz or maintenant on dit aux
gens vous n'aurez plus de chaudières à
gaz c'est pas trop bon alors qu'on les a
incités à faire des méthaniseurs pour
produire du gaz qu'on injecte
directement avec des investissements
lourds et des investissements déjà de
quelques années sur les biogarburants de
première génération et ces
investissements sont toujours pas
amortis et on sait qu'il y a un combat
mener faut redonner confiance et on
compte souvent Madame le Ministre parce
qu'on a appris que la Commission
européenne remettait remettait encore
justement la stratégie française de
détaxation vous l'avez dit des
biocarburants et que ça ne pouvait pas
dur er et que on a compris que au niveau
de la Commission européenne les
biocarburant il les allaient dans le nez
et que des décisions à les prises donc
les acteurs du terrain qui ont investi
sont particulièrement inquiets comment
répondez-vous madame la ministre elle
s'est inquiétude
bien Bernard buis
merci Madame le Ministre pour vos propos
clairs et précis j'avais juste une
question un complément à celle de ma
collègue Martine Berthet sur l'hydrogène
parce que de nombreuses lignes SNCF sont
inélectrifiables on va dire ça comme ça
parce qu'elles sont trop longues et
quelques fois trop vite il y aurait pas
la place et donc je pense que là dessus
il faudrait qu'on aille plus vite sur la
mise en place de véhicules hydrogène
avec des trains moteurs est-ce qu'il y
aurait une possibilité pour inciter la
SNCF à travers je sais pas quel moyen
mais aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression qu'on
va vraiment très lentement
et bien je vous repasse la parole madame
la ministre alors sur les
investissements étrangers dans la dans
le travail que nous menons nous
communiquons aussi sur la part de valeur
ajoutée énergie par énergie française et
européenne donc pour vous donner un
exemple alors je vous rassure l'éolien
c'est pas 0 % heureusement mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a des énergies où nous
sommes bien meilleurs le nucléaire plus
de 90% de valeur ajoutée française il y
a pas beaucoup de secteurs on a plus de
90% de valeur ajoutée française le
biogaz effectivement et je dis ici parce
qu'il y a des
usages de biogaz qui sont assez
multiples et je vais vous rassurer moi
je viens de signer les textes qui ont
été publiés au Journal officiel
aujourd'hui de soutien du biogaz et de
valorisation à 12% du tarif mais la
réalité du biogaz aujourd'hui c'est que
c'est 10 terawatt-heure injecté la
réalité de notre consommation de gaz
naturel c'est 500 terawattheure
donc c'est 2%. donc même si ils font
très bien très fort très vite
ça fera pas 500 terawattheure c'est
juste ce point là que nous soulignons on
va pas plus loin nous nous développons
le biogaz dans les capacités que nous
avons monsieur le sénateur salmon a
rappelé le sujet de la biomasse de
disponibilités de la biomasse et de
capacité aussi je dirais d'acceptabilité
de ces installations je sais pas si on
est prêt du jour au lendemain multiplier
par 10 nos installations de
méthanisation sur le territoire
sur le territoire la dimension
territorialité je vais également vous
rassurer
la loi que vous avez votée sur
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables est une loi de
planification énergétique c'est vous qui
l'avez souhaité d'ailleurs ça ne
figurerait pas dans le texte initial
porté par le gouvernement
et ça a été co-écrit on va dire par les
parlementaires et les associations
d'élus donc maintenant
cette planification des énergies
renouvelables elle va se mettre en
oeuvre nous avons nous d'ores et déjà
ouvert le portail qui permet aux
collectivités au local d'avoir accès aux
informations de potentiel éolien de
potentiels sur d'autres énergies de
problèmes potentiellement
depr enfin de plantes prévention des
risques de biodiversité enfin donc ce
qui
permet de faciliter la le travail sur la
planification j'ai
une réunion par mois avec les préfets de
région pour faire le point sur cette
planification j'en aurai une
prochainement avec les tous les préfets
de départements et je dois avoir un à
deux webinars avec l'ensemble des
associations des lieux pour
préciser la mise en oeuvre de la loi les
délais les informations utiles les
questions qu'ils ont pour y répondre
effectivement baliser cela et la sont
pas très prochainement sortir me
permettrai de vous y renvoyer aussi
parce que c'est ça vocation à être une
aide à la décision pour tout le monde
des descriptifs sur chaque énergie
renouvelable en quatre pages qui permet
d'avoir accès à la quantité déployée le
coût le délai de
d'un projet
la dimension
d'empreintes françaises et européenne
enfin tout ce dont on a besoin
finalement pour avoir très vite en
quatre pages qu'est-ce qu'il faut savoir
sur une énergie le foncier que ça couvre
pour la puissance le taux d'efficacité
etc etc donc vraiment un accompagnement
porté par par l'ADN donc cette
planification
territoriale elle démarre ça va être un
exercice complexe mais c'est un exercice
qui va nous permettre de je pense
faire de nos élus des entrepreneurs de
l'énergie sur nos territoires et de
monter vraiment d'un cran en termes de
partage des enjeux énergétiques et de
capacité à déployer de nouveaux projets
sur la question de la Commission
européenne je vais vous rassurer ce type
de texte qui sont des textes sur la
fiscalité je suppose l'unanimité
c'est difficile à atteindre l'unanimité
au niveau européen déjà la majorité
qualifiée vous pouvez l'entendre parfois
par quelques éclats
vous mentionnez monsieur Laura porteur
un texte qui n'est pas encore
complètement bouclé donc l'unanimité bon
on n'y est pas encore et on est vigilant
sur la question des lignes et SNCF que
vous mentionnez alors effectivement
l'hydrogène commence à être déployée
plutôt sur le train de les trains de
voyageurs avec un soutien financier de
l'État aux rames qui ont été achetés par
un certain nombre de collectivités
locales je pense aux régions puisque de
mémoire il y a Occitanie
Bourgogne Franche-Comté Auvergne
Rhône-Alpes et je crois que il y a
nouvel Aquitaine mais sous réserve je me
trompe peut-être entre dans Grand Est
Grand Est pardon donc ça c'est un
premier point d'accompagnement en lien
avec Alstom le biocarburant je l'ai
indiqué en propos liminaire peut jouer
un rôle sur ce type de ligne qui sont
difficiles à électrifier pour le coup ce
genre de situation on est sur un usage
qui peut faire du sens donc là encore
à chaque fois c'est cette approche qu'on
ne peut pas électrifier quelles sont les
alternatives les plus efficaces les
moins coûteux les plus territoriales les
celles qui ont les meilleurs retombées
industrielles et d'emplois pour
prononciateurs c'est comme ça qu'on
essaye de raisonner
si vous avez encore 5 minutes je pense
que vous devez partir peut-être à
l'Assemblée
simplement peut-être deux points rapides
dans ce cas-là
vous nous proposez et on partage ça
c'est d'ailleurs dans les textes un
raisonnement disons global de
planification bon alors en mesure bien
qu'il y a un centre d'inconnu parce que
rien que dans les champs qui sont les
nôtres biocarburant carburant
synthétique hydrogène vert quand on met
bout à bout toutes les incertitudes
technologiques la nécessité quand même
de pas faire des choix trop trop avant
bon les difficultés liées à la
compétitivité ou à l'impact sur les
filières on mesure bien c'est difficile
mais
ce raisonnement peut-être que dans 5 ans
ou 10 ans on dira on a fait des
prévisions et on en est très éloigné bon
c'est pas si simple que ça bon et nous
on a plutôt quand même on est plutôt
parti quand même des territoires et un
ensemble d'acteurs qu'on a rencontrés
bon alors je demande si on va arriver à
faire matcher les deux
un paradoxe entre un raisonnement
englobant raisonnement stratégique qui
est très ambitieux et quand même quand
je vous dis l'aérien ou l'hydrogène
c'est vrai qu'on a le sentiment qu'on
est sur des appels à projet donc être
n'est pas trop ambitieux sur une volonté
de tout planifier exercice intellectuel
formidable un peu administratif et pas
assez ambitieux sur des effets leviers
sur lesquels on devrait peut-être mettre
l'accent ça c'est le premier point
deuxième point donné seulement là un peu
effleuré
rtems SIM qu'il faut
devoir consommer jusqu'à 640 térawatts
en 2035
or le scénario médian prévoyait
d'arriver à 650 en 2050
j'ai deux petites questions en début de
votre propos vous avez ce point de vue
que je partage j'ai dit qu'il valait
mieux en termes de rendement utiliser
directement l'électricité je me suis
donc intéressé ce qu'on appelle
l'autoroute électrique pour les poids
lourds je parle pas par caténaire mais
par induction je voudrais savoir si
c'est toujours en étude ou si ça vous
intéresse toujours et en écoutant tout
ce qu'on consomme aujourd'hui en
terrawater
venant des énergies fossiles et ce que
l'on pourra avoir demain en énergie
renouvelable j'ai le sentiment que il y
a un déficit et donc comment on peut
résorber ce difficile c'est la question
de la sobriété comment et pour qui
alors
d'une certaine manière vous recoupez sur
RTE et les 600 40 questions me
semble-t-il donc sur la question d'un
planification cette planification
je l'ai indiqué
elle a elle est construite aujourd'hui
avec
les élus locaux
les filières les organisations
syndicales parce que nous paraît
important qu'elles soient aussi autour
de la table et
les experts et les acteurs de la société
civile en particulier les organisations
environnementales pour avoir au fond
tous les points de vue dans la même
pièce et il y a un exercice que je fais
en parallèle donc théoriquement si on
fait le fil tel que le prévoir notre
système de planification celui que vous
avez voté vous avez une loi de
programmation énergique climat qui se
décline ensuite dans un décret qui est
une programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie et un deuxième décret qui est
la stratégie nationale bas carbone
vous avez souhaité qu'il y ait une
régionalisation de la PPE la
programmation progrès annuelle de
l'énergie donc programmation purement
donne lieu à une régionalisation avec
des objectifs qui sont donnés région par
région les régions s'en emparent et les
inscrivent dans qui peuvent ensuite
éventuellement être en résonance avec
les pceats lorsque j'enchaîne ça ou de
la du fait que ça donne un peu le
tournis en termes d'enchaînement de de
travaux de nature réglementaire ou
législatives
j'enchaîne aussi des délais et donc du
côté de 2025 peut-être 2026 les régions
ont un Fredette mise à jour de la PPE
bon on en est parlé avec Harold Delga et
les autres patrons de région pour
arriver à la conclusion que rien ne nous
empêchait d'avoir un travail à qui
démarre ici et maintenant qui aura une
double vertu c'est à dire nous de donner
des trajectoires nationales et de dire
regarder par exemple on réhausse grosso
modo de 15% de notre trajectoire
photovoltaïque
est-ce que ça donne chez vous quand on
fait ça
par rapport à votre Fadette en
commençant d'ailleurs par vérifier que
la somme des stradettes égale la PPE
nationale ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui bon ça disons que c'est
secondaire est-ce que ça marche et de
façon à avoir en temps réel les impasses
et Aurore peut-être les gisements sur
lesquels les élus locaux se sont en
capacité de faire moi je m'attends j'ai
déjà cette conversation ce matin avec le
président de centre Val de Loire qui me
dit sur ça je me sur ça je me sens je
pense qu'on peut être plus ambitieux sur
tel type de technologie je veux pas
rentrer dans le détail dont je vous
donnerai pas le nom des technologies
j'ai vraiment j'ai trop d'opposition sur
le terrain je pense que c'est même pas
que je veux pas en faire je n'y
arriverai enfin je sens pas la capacité
à déployer réellement ce type de projet
sur le territoire au rythme où on
mentionne la théoriquement autour d'une
vision donc cet exercice là je pense il
doit être fait en parallèle
éventuellement ne pas s'interdire de
déboucher sur une contra visualisation
qui retrouvera ses droits quand le sera
d'être sera publié etc mais on a le
droit de travailler en temps masqué on
sait tous qu'il va falloir plus de
renouvelable plus d'énergie et plus
d'économies donc toutes les décisions
que nous prenons qui vont dans le sens
aujourd'hui de plus d'économies de plus
d'énergie sont des décisions sans regret
à fortiori si on se donne un coup de de
du mégawater comme étant
compétitif si on se dit aujourd'hui que
ce qu'on produit en dessous de 100 euros
du mégawattheure et compétitif ça vous
donne déjà un signal assez clair au
niveau territorial sur ce que vous
pouvez faire vous pouvez faire si vous
dit ensuite vous êtes aujourd'hui et ça
on sait le dire dépendant à x% des
énergies fossiles et donc si vous voulez
réduire ne serait-ce que de 50% cette
dépendance voilà ce qu'il faut produire
en plus ça donne des orientations alors
génériques à des élus locaux mais enfin
ils savent sans dépatouiller pour
commencer
à tracer des
objectifs donc
cette planification effectivement elle
ne peut pas être techno pratique parce
que ça ne suffira pas en revanche elle
doit être fondée sur la science et
fondée sur des calculs c'est ce qui nous
évite de dire qu'on va faire trois fois
de la biomasse pour produire du biogaz
ça c'est le risque sur la partie
électrique vous avez raison de dire que
la question de la maîtrise énergétique
est clés aujourd'hui on a un objectif
qui est dans les textes européens de
réduction de 30% de consommation
d'énergie à horizon 2030 sur une base
2012 donc pour vous donner par rapport à
2022 c'est plutôt 20%
jusqu'ici le levier principal qui a été
travaillé c'est l'efficacité énergétique
nous y avons rajouté l'année dernière la
sobriété énergétique compte tenu de ce
qu'il y a derrière l'efficacité
énergétique je dirais que l'objectif que
nous nous donnons c'est que nous
passions un CAP de l'ordre de 10-15% sur
la sobriété énergétique et que ce soit
notre
amorti si on n'arrive pas à faire la
partie efficacité énergétique vous voyez
ce que je veux dire c'est à dire qu'on
fasse bien les 30% mais qu'on s'oblige à
avoir un double gisement de réduction
d'économies d'énergie qui soit à la fois
sobriété on se donne un objectif qu'on
suit et de l'autre côté toute la partie
efficacité énergétique avec notamment la
rénovation thermique pour éviter de se
trouver en 2030 avec une situation
n'aurait pas fait assez vite la
rénovation thermique et où effectivement
là on aura un risque de pas produire
suffisamment d'électricité par rapport à
nos objectifs c'est ça la méthode qu'on
aurait en tête encore une fois c'est
travailler avec vos représ donc
et vous allez avoir tout loisir aussi de
vous en emparer lorsque le texte
arrivera au Parlement sur des autoroutes
électriques par induction on me souffle
que il y aura un appel à projet dans
France 2030 sur ce sujet qui viendra
même si c'est un sujet dont le on pense
que la réalisation pratique est post
2030 donc c'est plutôt pour l'étape 2030
2050 mais ça fait partie des
technologies qui sont regardées par le
Secrétariat général à l'investissement
merci beaucoup madame la ministre merci
de nous avoir accordé de votre temps et
de votre éclairage je vous remercie au
nom de l'ensemble de mes collègues